did you all know david arquette is a
licensed bob ross painting instructor he
teaches people how to paint like bob
ross it's
kind of unrelated but i thought it was
awesome thought you should know
so scream is actually scream five but
it's just called scream which movies do
nowadays which is probably why they did
it because it screams super self-aware
allegory as to movies and fandoms so
it's yeah it's probably why they did it
they even make a joke in this movie
about that concept point is as someone
who has to title this video is very
annoying and for my own sanity i'm just
going to go ahead and call this movie
scream 5 as i'm talking about it right
now because scream is scream 5. it's
been 10 years since it's been 10 years
since the end of the scream trilogy now
we have new victims which means new
suspects because that's how scream works
ghostface is back there is an intriguing
story based element as to who ghostface
is killing and why now with the passing
of the late great west craven this is
not directed by wes craven it is
directed by the directing duo of ready
or not which completely works because
ready or not was pretty awesome also if
i had to pick directors for another
screen movie it would be the directors
of ready or not also kevin williamson
didn't write this scream movie but he
has a producer on it so he's still
involved right out the gate gonna give
you what you want to know the ghostface
murders how are they savage ghostface is
just one of the coolest greatest killers
in the annals of horror movies it's not
just the killings it's the playful
banter ghostface has the phone calls
that's where i suspended my disbelief in
this movie of all of it the biggest
suspension of disbelief i was like the
girl at the beginning has a landline
very 90s of you i mean granted you look
at my retro game room you'd be like
that's very 90s of you but in practical
application for the movie's sake it did
a lot for a scene where she's talking to
ghostface but also texting someone i
thought that was a lot of fun but man
the savage [ __ ] talk the suspense and
the killings top tier ghost face in this
movie i really dug the ghostface
killings great build up great payoff
ghostface is a dick a complete
[ __ ] that's why we love
ghostface and not only does this movie
have a whole new group of friends this
whole crew of friends that it revolves
around the main victim slash protagonist
is completely new as well which was the
case in screen four but not to this
degree i mentioned this because the
marketing looks like sydney prescott
comes like all right sweet let's put him
in the ground not really how this movie
plays out i mean she's in it obviously
and they do use her but not until the
latter part of the movie chess metaphor
right we've all seen the queen's gambit
we're all down with our chess metaphors
fantastic in the original scream i felt
like nev campbell was the queen on the
chessboard the badass the focal point
the opposing sides going we take the
queen out and it's game over essentially
who are we getting scream four nev
campbell was more like the king not
always in on the action but still
definitely a focal point the story still
felt like it was revolving around her
scream five i felt like sydney prescott
was
that rook you know the rook that you
keep there until the end game in which
you might have to castle then you use
the rook right that's that's kind of
what sydney felt like in here of the
surviving scream alums david arquette
dewey he's actually in it for a sizeable
amount which we'd love to see that he is
a legend but on a personal level i did
feel the absence of nev campbell for the
majority of this movie because
personally for me she is my scream queen
nev campbell as sydney prescott is quite
simply perfect every year i re-watch
scream every year is another year where
i'm like she is so [ __ ] good in these
movies which is also a very tough act to
follow it's like alright anyone who
wants to pick up the mantle of being the
main character in a scream movie good
luck i will say among the new lead there
is a strong family dynamic if you're
going to have sydney sitting on the
benches for most of the film have a
strong family dynamic as for the new
crew of friends and suspects there are a
couple standouts but they didn't stand
out to me as much as the crew and other
screen movies i've seen they do have fun
with the banter and the finger pointing
though sometimes it got a little
heavy-handed for me i get it though in a
world of self-aware meta horror movie
references scream was a trailblazer for
that but it almost feels like so many
movies do that very self-aware thing
that if this movie did it to the degree
the original screen movies did it
wouldn't stand out anymore so if you
want a scream movie to stand out it has
to be crazy over the top i get it but i
felt like rocket raccoon all like it's a
bit much regardless i can appreciate
having fun with the horror movie tropes
there was actually a great scene that's
kind of a scene within a scene within a
scene that i thought was one of the
coolest scenes in the movie so you know
there is give and take there some of the
characters though i was like dude the
finger pointing the finger pointing got
a bit much for me because friends in a
situation like this probably wouldn't
finger point it worked in the original
scream movie where they're all sitting
around and they're finger pointing like
oh you saying that i killed her was that
before or after he sliced and diced it
worked as a high school conversation
that high school friends in the 90s
would have in the sense that they're
only kind of half serious but it works
to let the audience know that the
audience is supposed to think like that
you're supposed to suspect everyone you
look at the screen movies after that the
finger pointing among the characters in
the movie was pulled back because the
audience knew it's like yeah we're going
to do a scream movie and we know we're
supposed to suspect people so the fact
that these characters are all suspecting
each other and finger-pointing i was
like you all shouldn't be friends if you
actually think this granted is woodsboro
it's a place where douchebags slash
people up when they're your friends in
the end by the end by and large i
enjoyed scream five not my favorite
since the original or anything as i
stand here it's not even better than
scream four it's probably because i felt
scream four
had more of a purpose like beyond the
whole oh it's been 10 years and movies
and phantom are different so let's do it
in a world where in scream 3 the ghost
face killings were essentially pg-13
killings also screams always had comedy
in it they were horror movies with
comedy scream 3 i would classify as a
comedy first i felt like stream 4
existed to bring ghostface and the
scream franchise back on chorus story
kills horror movie allegory good horror
with comedy in it but to give the horror
first and foremost that extra flavor so
screen 4 felt like a return to form for
scream and it had that purpose this is
scream five because i'm sure we can make
it work but in the end by and large they
do make it work and i had fun with
scream five and the nitpicks i have with
some of the self-aware elements that
screams always had but in screen five
it's a bit on the nose some of the
support characters is feeling like
they're there to die they're not
standing out some others are a bit
unbelievable like they're caricatures of
scream characters but in the end it's
the brutal ghostface killings that makes
me go i can look past those other things
if you're here looking for some fun
bloody gory savage kills with some great
payoff i think that's how scream five is
going to grab you we'll say the movie
was a fun time no alcohol required or so
screen5 have you seen it what did you
think about it or how do you rank the
screen movies what's your ranking i feel
like i've asked you that in other screen
reviews i've done but hey spend some
time let's revisit it lists change
that's how they go but whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you